no one knows all the answers but I'll
mention two of them um let me say two
words television news television news
I'm 50 years ago when television news
was young the philosophy television news
is basically just broadcast news on
television it was reporters on
television somebody trying to say what
had happened that was what they did you
might have 30 minutes of news without a
single televised clip of anything just
somebody there sitting there reading the
news sometimes a great length that was
television news it was simply never to
inform nowadays never to entertain and
to play to the gallery it matters if
there are pictures it matters if they're
jokes you can tell what matters you'd
get people on and yell and scream at
each other that's really taking us down
a sad path every one says I think it's
true that's emphasized the notion that
the right way to have interaction is to
get very strong advocates who will call
each other name so i think it's striking
about the way the news is today take an
issue a contested issue abortion the war
whatever you like news today is verga to
telling us pills positions on these
issues candidates say it's very bad at
telling us why they have their positions
it strikes me that one of the jobs of a
news reporters not to say so and so is
for against abortion rights but what so
his argument why so and so believe that
I years ago I ran into a guy who was
retired reporter for a major newspaper
and he was lamenting what had happened
to the news and he was telling me how
when he was coming along in the 60s if
the president announced a new Urban
Affairs initiative the headline would be
the next day president announces Urban
Affairs initiative and the story would
be explaining what it was this is what
the president proposed that's the story
today he said and we had this meeting in
the 90s today he said the story would be
Republicans attack presidents Urban
Affairs initiative as the first
paragraph is a brief token summer was
having the second part was somebody
attacking it Third Reich is somebody
defending it you never take much time to
explain what it is the important thing
is who's going to win who's going to
lose who's on which
that's one thing certainly that's to
help take us down but that's not the
only thing luxury is the big problem
luxury we've been a generation here I
speak of myself in the other baby
boomers who's had everything we don't
feel the wave ever they were constantly
complaining everything's going wrong in
our lives but there's a sense which
compared to the rest of world we've had
everything with everything we could want
um and that's given us a lot of time to
ruminate uh maybe too much time to remit
I think our luxury has made us in
cautious in how we use democracy
hey